j'ai appris que on pouvait perdre la
personne qu'on aimait à tout moment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
président de la Fédération Française de
Football a tenu des propos très violents
contre Zinédine Zidane la question
c'était le Brésil c'est une icône
française Zidane le voir partir vous en
tant que Français voire partir Zinédine
Zidane dans une autre
sélectionneur du Brésil c'est vrai
on n'a pas la même opinion il peut aller
où il veut dans un club sélection j'y
crois à peine là ces derniers jours dans
Zinédine Zidane
franchement c'est surtout le tweet de
Kylian Mbappe qui donne une dimension
très très vite Zidane c'est la France on
manque pas de respect à la légende comme
ça c'est fou parce que il prend position
alors que c'est évident en fait c'est
pas la première fois que que les deux
voilà ont quelques difficultés à
s'entendre on se rappelle que juste
après le l'euro 2021 euh
Kylian Mbappe a failli arrêter l'équipe
de France parce qu'il y a eu des propos
racistes sur les réseaux sociaux à la
suite de son pénalty de finale face à la
Suisse qui sont pas et qu'il aille lui
annoncé et Noël le grec n'a cessé de
rappeler que dans le foot le racisme
Jonathan Zidane cousin Zinédine toi tu
as dû devenir fou hein ouais moi j'ai
pété un plomb la famille vous dites quoi
déjà sous le choc sous le choc après en
se levant ce matin surpris aussi et
content de voir les lentes solidarités
des des Français personnalité publique
et du peuple aussi
Didane on sait qui qu'il a pas besoin de
parler c'est que la France elle est là
pour lui et une fois de plus elle l'a
prouvé était moi aussi de rajouter
quelque chose et je sais que c'est votre
ami et je pense que pardonnez-moi c'est
un énorme caillou dans la chaussure de
Didier Deschamps
98 ils ont tous pris la parole ils ont
tous défendu Zizou que fait Didier
deschampsons
chez lui une intention de nuire c'est ça
que la France entière ne peut pas lui
pardonner il a une intention de punir
Zinédine Zidane en lui tend le traitant
comme une merde c'est la France lui
pardonnera jamais ça mais c'est ça c'est
ça en fait
pour pour les propos qu'a tenu monsieur
le grec alors dis-nous on peut pas
parler de Zidane comme ça merci c'est
une légende il a jamais été dans aucune
polémique il a toujours tout apporté
pour la France il a toujours
[Musique]
un homme de 31 ans avec qui tu étais en
couple depuis deux ans et c'est vrai que
toi aussi tu as vécu l'aventure tu vas
nous raconter dans un instant c'est vrai
que cette histoire il faut aller vous
allez me dire si vous trouvez ce concept
intéressant ou pas si vous trouvez que
ça va trop loin comme la téléréalité
aujourd'hui elle est en bout de course
elle est au bout du rouleau elle essaie
de se réinventer
en avant un inventant un concept ou on
pousse encore un petit peu plus le
curseur un petit peu plus trash mais ce
que je trouve un peu dégueulasse en fait
c'est que en fait vous vous voulez juste
passer à la télé c'est un programme de
téléréalité en fait avoir un
propriétaire
sur le dos de la fidélité sur le dos
d'une institution tiens
on s'est embrassé en fait c'est une
blague
non
je te jure c'est bon je me casse
moi j'ai une question à poser à Lina si
vous le permettez
dans l'émission avec Sofiane un homme de
31 ans et qui était en couple depuis 2
ans et c'est lui qui te pose un ultimum
voilà on avait une problématique ou
Sofiane devait aller vivre aux
États-Unis voulait que je le suive et
Sofiane devait partir dans les mois qui
suivait et j'ai pris ça comme une
opportunité en fait de vraiment vivre
une expérience qui pourrait me conforter
dans mon choix en fait
ou pas je savais pas si j'étais prête à
tout quitter pour partir avec toi
c'est la bien dit qu'il aurait pu juste
Ken et c'est tout moi il me l'a dit en
face
moi je me suis basée sur ce qu'on a dit
à ce moment là oui Sofiane me disait
qu'il y avait un feeling et qui a eu
plaisait bien et c'est bien ce que j'ai
dit j'ai dit Sofiane m'a dit s'il
pouvait te l'aurais fait donc c'est pas
ce que je pensais c'est ce qu'on m'a dit
aussi si il avait peur dans un autre
contexte c'est ça et en fait tu penses
qu'il a
il faut voir les épisodes autre chose
que je fais tu pars en couille tu fais
des crises pour rien moi je fais des
cris tu fais un truc alors que je t'ai
prévenu à plusieurs reprises Sofiane tu
disparais de ma vie en fait je suis
tellement gentil avec toi que tu crois
que je suis faible je crois je te le dis
moi l'amour je t'aime ouais mais l'amour
je m'en bats les couilles en fait du
jour au lendemain je me casse et j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] oh c'est fou là je te sens
remonter quand même non et on commence à
aussi se poser des questions sur son
couple et sur nous-mêmes en même temps
et du coup on passe par différentes
émotions bah là je passe par la colère
et par la
de revoir les images bah parce que c'est
pas facile de se voir comme ça moi j'ai
appris beaucoup de choses sur moi je
pensais vraiment que j'allais apprendre
des choses sur mon couple et
la vision du couple et la vie que je
voulais mener mais j'ai beaucoup plus
appris sur moi aussi vraiment tu as pris
quoi
bah j'ai appris que on pouvait perdre la
personne qu'on aimait à tout moment et
qu'il faut jamais prendre qui que ce
soit pour acquis mais vraiment
le 12 décembre dernier vous faisiez vos
courses au Lidl de Chaumont et tout a
basculé lors de votre passage en caisse
je me trouvais donc à la caisse
j'attends les payer mes courses et puis
j'étais un peu dans ma bulle et puis je
sens comme une agitation autour de moi
mais j'ai pas le temps de réaliser que
je me prends un coup derrière et donc au
début je croyais que c'était un coup de
bouteille
donc j'étais sonné à terre et puis je
coprais que je comprenais pas ce qui
m'est arrivé j'ai revu l'homme revenir
donc me donner un deuxième coup au
dessus de la tempe avec un hachoir oui
c'est à ce moment en fait voilà et là
c'est à ce moment-là que quand il était
à terre parce que c'est la première
c'est la première personne que j'ai vu
se prendre les deux coups de hache c'est
ça qui a fait que je suis intervenu au
moment où je suis voilà je suis rentré
dedans avec le chariot il a eu le temps
de se relever et puis de de partir
derrière avec la caissière qui l'a
emmené s'enfermer dans les toilettes et
pouvoir
enfin je sens le sang qui coule sur moi
donc je je m'enferme aux toilettes
justement avec la caissière qui m'a qui
m'a retenu la porte
et une fois arrivé devant le miroir
c'est là que je vois mes cicatrices
et je vois tout le sens qui sort de ma
tête
la pensée qui vient c'est je vais fermer
les yeux je vais appeler mon père et
puis je vais faire mes adieux
donc
j'ai pris mon téléphone je j'essaie
d'appeler mes premiers que mon téléphone
il fait n'importe quoi eux mon père il
comprend le plus important et puis il
prend la route
et juste après j'ai réussi à avoir mon
copain aussi j'avais mis une serviette
autour de moi donc je la prends je
commençais à faire des points de
pression
et je me dis bon les suivre dans sa
vallée
que autre chose à ce moment-là donc
quand on décrié autour de toi tu t'es
dit je peux pas téléphoner tu voulais te
parler à ton père tu voulais lui dire je
voulais appeler quelqu'un pour faire mes
aides tout simplement et puis
une fois que j'ai eu mon père au
téléphone mais complètement sorti de la
tête et la première chose que je lui ai
dit c'est il a une attaque à Lidl voilà
et encore je lui ai dit ne viens pas
Tariq considérer qu'il vous a sauvé la
vie oui je pense que il a contribué à me
sauver
vous l'avez revu Tarik avant de voir ici
ou pas du tout oui en fait j'ai revu
entre temps j'ai revu à Hajar donc c'est
l'aide aux victimes
c'est vu quelques temps je les remercie
à ce moment-là encore une fois et voilà
on est venu ensemble alors vous êtes
venu ensemble les prix dans ma voiture
tu viens avec moi parce qu'il était
stressé allez
bien ici rien que lui il est chez lui
exactement aujourd'hui est-ce que tu
arrives à reprendre une vie normale
j'essaye je suis je suis au mieux je
suis avec mon copain mon copain au
départ il me disait à la maison il faut
que tu te reposes mais sorti t'es
retourner au Lidl d'ailleurs non jamais
non je crois que j'y retournerai pas
honnêtement j'arrive pas
un petit message à passer
il y a trois jours j'ai perdu ma
grand-mère
et je voulais lui rendre hommage
et donc je vais lui faire un gros bisous
tout là-haut et
je vais dire que je l'aime
[Musique]
ce matin à Paris les voyageurs de la
gare du Nord ont assisté à une scène
terrifiante une attaque à l'arme blanche
l'homme a pu être rapidement arrêté par
des passants et par les forces de
l'ordre il a été neutralisé par les
forces de l'ordre qui elle-même ont fait
usage de leur arme
féliciter l'ensemble des effectifs qui
sont intervenus avec une efficacité et
puis ils ont fait preuve d'un grand
professionnalisme et puis une pensée
aussi pour les six victimes dont le
policier et une victime civile qui est
actuellement qui a été grèvement blessée
donc ce matin vers 6h45 un individu au
moyen d'un poinçon artisanal attaquer
plusieurs personnes au niveau du parvis
de la gare du Nord ensuite il y a des
civils qu'ils ont tenté de s'interposer
il est rentré dans la gare du Nord au
niveau du hall et là il a agressé
plusieurs autres personnes et s'en suit
des policiers de la police aux frontière
ont entendu des cris au niveau du hall
sont descendus très rapidement et ont
tenté de neutraliser l'individu un
collègue à ceinturer l'individu en
question et l'individu en a profité donc
du coup pour lui planter l'arme blanche
au niveau de la nuque et ensuite vous
avez un policier hors service et
d'autres collègues qui étaient avec le
collègue de la police aux frontière qui
ont fait usage de leur arme pour notre
Alizée individu alors la police
intervenue en une minute une minute 15 à
peu près exactement voilà donc c'est
vrai que ça a évité un énorme drame
encore plus grave que c'est déjà que
c'est un drame et c'est vrai que vos
collègues ont été incroyables ils
étaient autorisé à tirer là ah oui on
était dans on était complètement dans le
cadre dans la légitime défense et c'est
les images très difficiles donc là vous
avez les civils qui s'interposent et
c'est dingue c'est incroyable c'est
incroyable
vous rendez compte de ça sur la gare du
Nord on sait que c'est extrêmement
dangereux est-ce que il y a pas moyen de
renforcer les effectifs bah nous en tout
cas c'est une revendication
beaucoup renforcé certains services et
d'autant les amis de côté je vais pas
parler de la banlieue parce que c'est
encore c'est encore pire mais
aujourd'hui d'intervention c'est pas mal
l'homme à une occupé il devrait pas être
sur le territoire comment on peut
accepter qu'il y a des gens des des je
sais même pas combien ils sont sur le
territoire des gens qui n'ont pas qui ne
peuvent pas être légalement sur le
territoire
bilatéraux
c'est une fatalité on accepte et on
prend ses risques là tous les jours et
on en parle comme ça
les habitants d'un immeuble ont trouvé
le courage de s'opposer aux dealers
se relaient jour et nuit au pied de leur
immeuble pour monter la garde le bus
empêcher des trafiquants de drogue de
revenir s'installer dans leur quartier
c'est incroyable parce que c'est vrai
qu'on se dit comment est venu l'idée
déjà comment ça s'est passé ben en fait
moi j'étais venu pour voir mon père
parce que moi je suis plus une locataire
d'ici j'ai grandi au campanule je suis
née et mon père il habite toujours et en
fait je suis venu le voir pour le
souhaiter la bonne année et en fait en
bas j'ai vu 15 personnes qui avaient
reçu les lieux sur des tables sur des
chaises avec des canapés porte de
l'ordre ils ont eu je crois des milliers
d'appels sans être marseillaise ils ont
eu vraiment des milliers d'appels ils
ont fait quoi alors
ils étaient là
avec nous
ils étaient là avec nous le problème
c'est que malheureusement quand tu
viennes ils ont rien sur eux donc ils
arrêtent il les relâchent deux heures
après ton chat il descendu en bas les
parties prendrais un sandwich et une
canette et moi je l'ai je l'ai compagnie
puisse partir on m'a demandé qu'est-ce
que je faisais là
je suis venu vous tenir compagnie
d'accord c'est parce que c'est mon
bâtiment et vous n'êtes pas d'ici c'est
pas nos enfants c'est même pas des
enfants de nos quartiers mais là
aujourd'hui ça fait 11 jours du coup
qu'on est en bas donc on a décidé de
médiatiser l'affaire parce qu'on sait
que quand on y met les médias
ça avance on sait très bien que la
drogue du coup il y a des armes derrière
qu'on peut avoir des revendications des
représailles pardon mais après
honnêtement ont peur pour avoir peur on
préfère avoir peur maintenant que
d'avoir peur dans dans six mois si nous
envahi la cité et qu'on ne peut plus
sortir donc on préfère avoir peur
maintenant pour sauver nos familles et
pour sauver les personnes âgées pour
sauver cette résidence qui est vraiment
propre qui est belle qui est calme
surtout qui est vraiment calme c'est
c'est décevant parce que on est on est
vraiment fatigué ça fait 11 jours qu'on
lutte midi 3h du matin de midi à 3h du
matin on est en bas on a on a réussi à
faire un collectif tous ensemble et là
du coup on a une équipe de 8 vigiles qui
sont assez sermentés donc qui vont être
sur 7 et on va essayer d'abord d'autres
trucs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]